let's go next to bobby from jersey bobby
welcome to the show
bobby from jersey welcome you're on the
air
hello david could you hear me yes now i
can
uh tremendous so what do you think about
gun debates it makes it so messy of a
topic to debate
what makes it messy well i think that
it's it's really a cultural issue
there are lots of people in the united
states
who are either
so enmeshed in gun culture
and i will also say that there's people
who are just viscerally opposed to guns
for cultural reasons
that it's very difficult to get past it
and to think about it like we would any
other uh kind of empirical
circumstance
and say okay well
what is the likelihood of a defensive
use of guns and are we really curtailing
the second amendment if we have some
restrictions and you know all these
different things now i know where i come
down on it i don't really have i mean
listen i'm disgusted by what we might
call uh man how do i say it like
uh kind of like rural
rural right-wing gun culture i find it
completely disgusting and i want nothing
to do with with
the folks who are part of that but at
the same time it's not just for me about
the guns i have lots of friends who are
liberal gun owners and they're
responsible and they want licensing and
insurance and they're safe with their
guns and all these different things it's
like hey we have a second amendment
you're not doing anything wrong you're
not kind of like a fetishist where
you're fetishizing guns and whatever all
these different things so i think
because people are so ideologically
connected to the issue it prevents us
from really speaking substantively and i
think if we spoke substantively we would
we would come down on we need way more
regulations on guns
yes i completely agree and i feel it's
they say that it just
it's pretty difficult to debate emotion
rather than like over empirical evidence
well that's going back to the
conversation earlier about abortion
imagine that we got an answer about when
life begins or when a fetus is a person
that was like scientifically definitive
first no one you will never have actual
everybody agreeing with it and even if
we did it wouldn't change everyone's
mind about abortion anyway so it's one
of these things where the vast majority
of the debate even if you resolve it
won't actually resolve the broader issue
yes yeah i feel like too many people
have such a binary um a binary view on
like a lot of it a lot of issues and i
haven't
that's something that really annoys me
thank you david all right my pleasure
thank you so much for the call we're
getting some solid calls today guys i
have to say let's hope nobody nobody
ruins it now